marvel has a stellar track record but
they've also canceled a number of tv
shows before they were even made
including a line of adult cartoons
spearheaded by chelsea handler so what
went wrong keep watching to find out
when marvel television was just getting
off the ground in the early 2010s one of
its initial projects was to relaunch the
hulk on tv considering how successful
the bill bixby show had been in the 70s
it was no surprise that marvel was
looking to return the character to that
medium guillermo del toro was hired to
shepherd the project and at 2011's san
diego comic-con the project was said to
have a tone somewhere between smallville
and twilight this was all decided on
before mark ruffalo replaced edward
norton as bruce banner in the avengers
though the success of the avengers
changed everything suddenly a hulk tv
show didn't make sense by october 2012
del toro admitted the project had
stalled out the hulk is capable of many
incredible feats but getting an abc
program of his own in the wake of the
avengers wasn't one of them
the punisher made his way to television
through an extended supporting role in
daredevil before spinning off into his
own solo netflix program in 2017 with
john bernthal playing the character the
punisher ripped through all sorts of
unseemly villains in his time as a
streaming service fixture that almost
didn't happen though because back in
2011 fox announced they'd greenlit a
pilot for a different punisher tv show
hailing from criminal minds showrunner
ed bernero
translating a character as vicious as
the punisher to the world of broadcast
television would require some heavy
reworking
as planned the show would have
reimagined frank castle as an nypd
detective who takes on the punisher
persona at night which would be a
massive departure for the character for
better or worse though the show never
saw the light of day no future
developments were announced and the
project just disappeared clearing the
way for the netflix version
in 2011 marvel television showed up at
san diego comic-con with a whole slew of
high-profile tv projects to show off
these included early versions of jessica
jones and cloak and dagger as well as
one show that never got made mockingbird
yes the future agents of shield
character was once set to headline her
own tv show for abc family it would have
been very different though marvel
television head jeff loeb revealed it
was about a young bobby morse who as a
freshman science whiz at a silicon
valley university gets recruited by
shield and has to balance spywork with
the life of a normal student this
proposed mockingbird show seemed like a
natural fit for abc family's programming
lineup however no further news emerged
after all the razzle dazzle of an sdcc
announcement of course a new incarnation
of morse went on to be a pivotal part of
agents of shield closing the book on
this mockingbird tv show speaking of
which
following the demise of her planned abc
family show mockingbird got a second
shot at headlining a television program
with marvel's most wanted a proposed
agents of shield spin-off this would
have seen bobby morse and lance hunter
going on the lamb to have their own
action-filled adventures separate from
phil coulson and company that's the fun
stuff i love doing the action the show
had numerous stops and starts with abc
passing on the show in may of 2015 only
for the network to revive their interest
by the end of the summer
the pilot was shot in early 2016 and
agents of shield even built up the
spin-off by giving morse and hunter a
concrete farewell despite all this
marvel's most wanted met a discouraging
demise abc passed on the pilot in may of
2016 saying that it was quote not as
strong as some of the other pilots that
we shot
in the mid 2010s 20th century fox got
busy expanding the x-men over to tv with
legion airing on fx and the gifted
playing on fox one other proposed fox
program was hellfire which would have
centered on the villainous hellfire club
at the likes of sebastian shaw and emma
frost belong to the group previously
appeared in x-men first class and the
show would have followed the adventures
of an agent who infiltrates the evil
organization but hellfire never got off
the ground beyond an initial
announcement and a vague promise to air
in 2016.
after the show was confirmed to be dead
producer lauren schuller donner revealed
the reason behind dumping hellfire
simply stating quote it was too many
characters and not enough depth of
character
the bigger they are
the more pieces they make
following the success of shows like rick
and morty it looked like marvel
television was aiming to make a big
swing in the adult cartoon genre through
a series of cartoons on hulu among those
proposed shows was a series titled tigra
and dazzler which would have starred the
two titular superheroes as imagined
through the comedic filter of chelsea
handler
sadly trouble emerged for the project in
december of 2019 when it was first
reported that the show's writing staff
had been fired though handler remained
tigra and dazzler was eventually
canceled the following month the demise
came about as marvel studios took over
control of marvel television with the
division deciding to shift its focus
over to programming for the disney plus
streaming service
though he started out as a minor player
in the comics brother voodoo has become
quite a prominent character in his own
right in fact he's garnered such
importance that he even took the
sorcerer supreme mantle from dr strange
no wonder then that such a notable
superhero would be eyeballed for a tv
series with the sci-fi network looking
to get a brother voodoo show off the
ground way back in 2003 the plan for
voodoo was to film a 2-hour tv movie
that could also double as a pilot for a
proposed series but it never got beyond
the press release still though his
sci-fi series went nowhere there's hope
yet for another brother voodoo
adaptation the appearance of his twin
brother daniel drumm and doctor strange
indicates he could have a future in the
marvel cinematic universe
poor howard the duck his solo
adaptations into other media rarely go
well despite being an incredibly popular
comic book character in the 1970s
howard's reputation was tainted by a
legendarily bad 1986 movie
you think i might find happiness in the
animal kingdom ducky
like they say thou love's strange
we could always give it a try and his
misfortune didn't end there after
decades of being a supporting figure in
the comics howard was poised to return
to leading duck status thanks to a
proposed hulu cartoon that never saw the
light of day the show was announced
alongside a slew of other hulu marvel
cartoons aimed at adult audiences each
of them were handed high-profile
behind-the-scenes talent with kevin
smith placed in charge of howard the
duck smith said let's be honest i'm not
talented enough to handle any of the
avengers but howard is definitely in my
wheelhouse his enthusiasm was palpable
but unfortunately it wasn't enough to
ensure the show made it onto hulu howard
the duck was cancelled roughly a year
after it was first announced with marvel
studios putting its focus on disney plus
series instead smith reacted to the news
with an appropriate statement on twitter
saying alas howard remains trapped in a
world he never made
that's it
no more mr nice duck
on the big screen marvel teamed up
superheroes for the avengers on netflix
its street level heroes created the
defenders for their planned hulu
cartoons marvel opted to go in a
different more comical direction by
merging warped irrelevant characters to
create the offenders a team-up between
howard the duck tigra and dazzler modoc
and hit monkey the show would have been
the culmination of all of hulu and
marvel's forays into adult animation
needless to say it never got made as the
cancellation of howard the duck and
tiger and dazzler scuttled three of the
show's proposed five members the
offenders never actually got cancelled
but with so many of its members never
getting their own series it seems
unlikely the offenders will ever exist
the second live-action version of ghost
rider made his debut in the fourth
season of agents of shield while
audiences were used to seeing the johnny
blaze version of the character the one
who appeared in shield was robbie reyes
played by gabriel luna the character was
both friend and foe and he garnered
positive remarks from critics and
viewers inevitably this led to whispers
in 2016 about ghost rider getting his
own show with the official announcement
coming in may of 2019
ghost rider was announced alongside
hellstrom as part of marvel and hulu's
commitment to develop horror-themed
superhero programming but that was about
as far as the marvel show got just
months after it was first announced news
broke that ghostwriter had been
cancelled likely due to the end of
marvel television
fresh off writing the screenplay for 12
years a slave writer john ridley had a
lot of high profile offers one of the
most exciting was his plan to leap into
the marvel cinematic universe with a
show for abc it was an endeavor that fit
many of ridley's interests thanks to the
anthology show american crime ridley had
plenty of experience with abc and his
work with dc comics meant ridley was no
stranger to comic book properties there
was no word on what character ridley
planned to tackle with the project but
he would later note that it would be
keenly aware of socio-political issues
and that he was aiming to create a
superhero tv show heavy on fun and abc
was still confident in the project
nearly two years after its announcement
as ridley toiled away on fine-tuning it
however news on the production stalled
from there in 2020 marvel announced
ridley would be writing some comics for
them but so far nothing on screen has
materialized
at one point in time marvel and abc were
keen on producing half-hour comedies
like damage control focusing on a
company that cleans up after superhero
battles damage control had a premise
that seemed ripe for both television and
for generating humorous situations abc
president paul lee noted in january 2016
that damage control is the one that's
going to be coming out this season we
hope it's going to be great in the end
though damage control was just one of
the many proposed tv shows that died on
the vine instead the group found its way
into the mcu through spider-man
homecoming at least keeping alive the
possibility we may see them again in
some form or another
at one point in time a new warriors show
starring squirrel girl as the leader of
a group of teenage superheroes was set
to be a major deal for the freeform
network not only would it have been a
major superhero series but it was set to
launch a bunch of spin-offs freeform's
carrie burke said the characters they've
chosen are all really singular and could
each carry the show that they're on
they're bound together as a band of
underdogs for as long as we choose with
this show but it's conceptually
tailor-made for spin-offs none of those
plans would ever see the light of day
though as new warriors was abruptly
dropped by freeform and even though new
warriors had a set cast and a finished
pilot producers failed to attract the
show a new home despite marvel
television's best efforts to find a new
network new warriors was ultimately
canned in 2019
after atlanta became a breakout success
fx wanted to continue being in the
donald glover business meanwhile the
colossal box office success of deadpool
meant that the entire fox conglomerate
wanted to put the hero in everything
these two desires collided with a
proposed cartoon for grown-ups that
would air on fxx and be spearheaded by
glover despite the show being littered
with talent though news broke in march
of 2018 that it wasn't going forward
glover took to twitter to deliver a
scathing 15-page script in which
deadpool explains why the show was never
made attributing the show's demise to
marketing concerns from marvel fx head
john landgraf later clarified that
marvel had pulled the plug and that fx
was still behind the program despite
deadpool co-creator rob lyfield saying
in may of 2019 that a new version of
this project was on the way no further
news on a raunchy deadpool tv cartoon
has emerged this merc with a mouth may
be unkillable as a character but his tv
show has ended up as dead as a doornail
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite marvel shows are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Applause]
[Music]
you